i look like ben shapiro what
who's ben shapiro wait a minute
is silo simon here okay i'm being
patient because i'm
i'm trying to find a side-by-side
comparison
between me and men shapiro or at least
pumpkin me
do we look similar
kind of right
like the same eyes and face
huh or no i mean at least we have like
facial features like a mouth and a nose
and eyes and brows
but he's missing a stem
anyway uh opponents not here let's abort
and let's play a new game
playing alex pierce
oh it's extra typo saying ben shapiro is
dark oh like dark mode
oh good luck to my opponent have fun
thank you
eric i love everything you do oh i love
you too
thanks so much shark
oracle oh let's play um
the gotham and chess e6b6
i still haven't bought this course but
i know he preaches this
and there's a benefit to
bishop f4 i was going to say there's a
benefit to delaying knight f6
is that i can play f5 and then knight f6
and just control
e4
not sure where my bishop developed the
bishop like this
probably go for some
some sort of simple harmonious
development
oh silo simon was not at the computer
that's okay
i made good use of my time waiting made
very good use of my time
okay so i gave up the bishop hair
but now i have knights and the idea the
idea is very simple to play knight e4
g5 g4 bring the queen in and eventually
mate somehow
i'll start with this
yeah this is very bird-like
or polar bear-like
yeah it's basically a reverse bird slash
polar bear
reminiscent of f4 on move one
it's also kind of reminiscent of a grand
prix attack
just with uh the pawn storm
combined with the queen maneuver so i
can't play queen h5
unfortunately oh this is rated blitz
um maybe i should take this seriously
could take
maybe queen g6 first just prepare g4
f3 might come and then i'll decide
whether to retreat
or capture
i could take with pawn
actually not sure i think i'll take with
pawn
the bishop's blocked but the pawn is
nice controlling
some squares gives me some space open
that file as well
so i'm going for probably some
eventual breakthrough
okay white's doing similar things on the
queen side
[Music]
i think c5 could be coming i can't
really play c my c5 myself because
d6 hangs
yeah bishop's actually decent here
what to do
i feel like this is the most flexible
move like i wasn't sure what my other
pieces want to do but i know my knight
should be here
and maybe g4 will kind of eventually
put the rook in oh i'm allowing oh
this is just a bad move
oh this is really bad
please don't do it
don't do it i was anticipating takes
takes and i thought i'm being clever
ah white's doing it
bishop is now a prisoner in its own home
maybe it's just quarantining it's going
to social distance for
a couple weeks and then
someday it will come alive
[Music]
this is really not pleasant
i just have to go all out for like some
attack a g4
how do i even make this work g4 h4
um so much
regret
let's play h4 first so i i want to play
g4 and not allow white to close the file
if it takes i probably have to take this
way
or i'll take this way
at this point i don't really care about
my bishop though i just care about
mating
interesting
so g4 takes rg7
this is really not comfortable
yeah let's go for this
i can't believe i allowed this that's so
bad
i gotta watch my time too
i also have to watch out for bishop h5
sneaky ideas
so maybe rook g7 at the right moment
the thing is this bishop isn't really
lively either like it's just
restricted by my pawns
so i can argue that okay i'm down the
bishop the white is also kind of down
the bishop
but obviously this bishop's more useful
hm
and queen a4 is coming
ah this is not what i wanted i i kind of
have to defend the bishop
because otherwise white's just crashing
through
no
how bad is this this is actually really
bad
or is it
okay
i have no idea what to do here play this
[Music]
move
okay some counter play
so i'm basically down the whole rook and
i have 10 seconds left
and i'm probably getting mated but apart
from that everything's okay
any tricks so i'm hoping for this this
this and then i can win a rook back
and then this and then this
please just try and make me on h8
it's crazy i don't think white has force
made here oh
that's probably annoying
when in down g5
no
ah good game though i got
squeezed positionally
good game well played
oh thanks so much for the kind words
alex pierce that was our first game
i feel like we played before
oh yeah i'm a pirate for halloween by
the way i forgot i changed that
it was an interesting position until my
bishop got stuck
it's kind of annoying though because the
combination of the
this tension and this diagonal
things are kind of crumbling
maybe i should have i should have
preserved bishop c8s so maybe this is a
better move
and then if c6 it's not so bad because
then later my bishop can
reactivate uh and if takes takes there's
queen c7
but i've rooked e7 here
okay i have to take a
away at least one lesson from this game
oh i'm still worse here though
oh i'm just worse the whole time what
oh i made the wrong decision i guess i
mis-evaluated
the pressure and i don't have any
attacks on the
or any like strong immediate attack on
the king's side
so if i take with bishop yeah the
bishop's happier here
compared to here
no costume today uh well
not yet but kind of my costume
is in my profile picture right
where was it here it is this is my
costume
can i like put this over myself
i'm just wondering if i can somehow use
a green screen
there's this like new trend on twitch
where people have like
these virtual avatars and it's not their
actual faces talking
but when they talk it's like avatar
talking and it's kind of interesting
maybe i would have done that if i had
more
expertise
yeah a v tuber
someday maybe i'll do that or maybe i'll
start a channel
i'll just have an avatar i'll i'll
change my voice and no one will
know it's me and then i'll just try and
grow from scratch
it could be interesting